our main story tonight concerns sports
the think OJ Simpson used to be famous
for the corona virus has taken its toll
on all manner of industries but the
world of sports was among those hit
hardest earliest and perhaps most
visibly because just think back to the
day that you first realized our lives
were gonna fundamentally change for a
while for many it was when this happened
two days before he tested positive for
coronavirus Utah Jazz all-star Rudy
Gobert did this to reporters microphones
in an interview and this morning the NBA
suspending the rest of its season the
unprecedented move shocking everyone
including Dallas Mavs owner Mark Cuban
just think about how astonishing
something has to be to shock Mark Cuban
keep in mind he's one of the Sharks on
Shark Tank
he's been pitched businesses like rent a
goat a service that rents out goats to
eat overgrown shrubs squirrel boss a
bird feeder that gives electric shocks
to squirrels and elephants chats a
literal stuffed elephant that you put in
the room to signal that there's
something uncomfortable to talk about
Mark Cuban has already seen the most
jaw-dropping inconceivable things this
world has to offer and it wasn't just
basketball vanishing suddenly since then
the NHL has suspended its season Major
League Baseball pushed back his opening
day to an unknown day's international
soccer league suspended games and the
Olympics were moved to next summer and
as shocking as these cancellations
seemed at the time the truth is there
was really no choice sporting events
with large crowds packed together are
the exact opposite of social distancing
and there are nightmare scenario during
a pandemic this Champions League match
in Milan in February was later likened
to a biological bomb after it was linked
to one of the deadliest outbreaks but
those sports shutting down was
emphatically the right thing to do
people have increasingly been asking
when they can return and few have a
slough der than this guy
I hope football can start and I told
them I think you might be able to they
may very well be able to I hope they can
start and I hope they can start with
people in the stands the fans want to be
back to you know they want to see
basketball and baseball and football and
hockey they want to see their sports we
have to get our sports back I'm tired of
watching baseball games at a 14 years
old but I haven't actually had too much
time to watch
I would say maybe I watch one batter and
then I get back to work
okay but here's the thing we actually
asked some experts about that and it
turns out that when the countries in the
middle of a pandemic that's killing many
thousands of Americans every single week
the correct number of batters from 2006
for the president to be watching is
actually zero but look he's not
entirely wrong there
the lack of sports is an emotional blow
to a lot of people and it's not just
emotional it's also financial by one
estimate the sudden disappearance of
sports will erase at least 12 billion
dollars in revenues and hundreds of
thousands of jobs in this country alone
and those jobs aren't just a high paid
athletes playing the games they also
include the many people who count on
sporting events for employment like
these to Philadelphia Stadium workers
Marvin's Spratly made $14 an hour as a
part-time grill cook for nearly two
years at Sixers flyers and Eagles games
it's a lot of stress on me a lot of
stress is that how that baby needs
pampers nyesha Johnson is a maintenance
worker at Phillies games I have food on
the table now I'm making it right at
this moment but I don't know what some
Merlot may bring yeah that's really
difficult and it's worth remembering
that although Philadelphia sports fans
are a horde of inhuman monsters who
deserve neither sympathy nor
understanding the people pay to tend to
those monsters really depend on their
monster money so given that the absence
of sport has caused such pain we thought
tonight we take a look at what sports
have become in the age of coronavirus
and what a path back for them might look
like and first let me say that the
sports world has been doing some truly
great things during this pandemic teams
and athletes have been donating and
raising money for charity with some even
selling branded face masks for
coronavirus related causes and despite
not being able to play teams have found
ways to stay engaged with their fans
online while modeling social distancing
at the Pittsburgh Pirates parrot posted
an at-home workout video the Chicago
Blackhawks mascot Tommy Hawk vacuumed
his apartment and Gritti once again blew
them all away without even trying
okay I don't know what's more amazing
there gritties incredible hand-eye
coordination the fact he seems to live
in an entirely empty apartment or the
discovery that his body
occasionally squeaks when it moves
presumably because evolutionarily
speaking gritties closest relative is a
used dog toy and it's not just mascots
athletes have been showing how they're
trying to work from home which has not
always been easy for them
for instance reigning NBA MVP Yanni's
and Entercom poo told reporters last
month that he's been unable to practice
because he doesn't have a hoop at his
house others have had to get pretty
creative to continue their training
whether it's an Olympic swimmer training
in a kiddie pool with a bungee cord an
Olympic runner creating makeshift
treadmills in a bathtub with Palmolive
an Olympic rock climber using her home
as a climbing gym or Brandon coin of the
Orioles squatting his dog who seems
utterly delighted by the situation but
not every at-home training session goes
smoothly as Dodgers pitcher Joe Kelly
recently discovered wondering how
quarantines going Joe is working on a
changeup
yeah honestly if I was Joe Kelly's wife
I'd never get that window fixed and I
just make him explain what happened
every time someone came over oh that
window Joe do you want to tell that
story because I kind of forget some of
the details like how many millions of
dollars you've been paid for your
ability to throw a baseball accurately
how big the net was and how many feet
you missed it by you just go ahead and
tell the story while I pull up the video
as for broadcasters who are reliant on
live events they are now in a truly
desperate situation while ESPN moved up
their 10-part Michael Jordan documentary
they've otherwise been strapped for
content airing video game versions of
baseball and basketball with
SportsCenter at one point actually
tweeting out this now you might be
wondering what the did I just see
well apparently that came from a Russian
show called stoned faces where
contestants slap each other as hard as
they can and this particular guy is a
renowned competitive slapper whose real
name doesn't matter because his nickname
is dumpling
which is just an outstanding name for
that man and at this point I don't need
to know anything else I'm all-in on
competitive slapping just tell me what
channels to subscribe to in order to
watch it and where to order my dumpling
Jersey so if we are all reaching the
point of desperation where we're
honestly willing to watch large men
slap each other in a windowless room
there is clearly a desire to restart
sporting events the question though
isn't why sports should come back it's
how that can safely happen because to do
it responsibly would be a mammoth
undertaking to do it irresponsibly
however turns out to be pretty easy the
state of Florida early on designated
professional sports and media production
with a national audience as an essential
service so long as it's closed to the
general public so the WWE has continued
staging shows in Florida holding matches
in front of empty chairs but that
requires a lot more people than just
those two wrestlers you need production
crews working together Inc
proximity and while the WWE maintains
its safety measures are as comprehensive
as they can possibly be one employee
wrote an anonymous letter to a florida
county commissioner asking them to shut
the tapings down because despite
sanitary precautions we cannot maintain
social distancing and have to touch
other people but it's easy to see why
CEO vince mcmahon doesn't mind them
taking that risk as he told investors on
a recent earnings call viewers want to
see new matches i think new content is
always a driver in terms of stimulating
interesting will happen obviously
everyone is pretty much starved for you
know for new content it could very well
be you're tired of watching Netflix and
what if they you know are unaware okay
um well first I would argue that the
risks of creating content the way that
you are seem to outweigh the benefits
right now and second no one on that call
registered your point there because you
just said stimulating strong men
underwear and crucially driver all in
the same sentence at which point
everyone's minds turned immediately to
getting absolutely bone crushed by Adam
driver
chokeslam me to hell you nasty shed Jam
your mandible claw down my throat you
irredeemable steer quick sidenote here a
lot of you might will be wondering where
I'm going with this bit if you're
anything like my stuff you're asking
questions like is this sexual or is it
violent and you're then unsatisfied when
the answer comes back yes if you like my
wife you might be asking should I be
worried about this with your concern
only growing when the answer is only if
you want to be and what if Adam driver
himself is he bothered by this continued
sexual ization he seems like a fairly
private guy who's generally
uncomfortable with attention making what
I'm doing
possibly some form of harassment he
might actually have pretty good grounds
to have me reprimanded legally to which
I say do it slap a restraining order on
to you for lon block begging me to stop
you menacing obstacle and it's not just
that WWE their competitor aew is also
taping shows in Florida and the UFC just
last week started hosting matches in
Jacksonville and while they couldn't fly
in international fighters for that
their president Dana White has devised
an insane workaround fight island is
real fight island is a real thing it's
really happening the infrastructure is
being built right now on the island I'm
ready to go yes the UFC is apparently
building a facility on a private island
that they're calling fight island now is
that a clever name is it the perfect
name yes because it's the first thought
an idiot would have if they wanted to
name a private island where fights
happen now we could have called it brawl
Hamas or Puerto raucous or are we Maui
or Slam Miguel but he didn't he didn't
do that and he didn't even go with the
obvious name for an island where you
staged UFC fights which is simply UFC
look at me Dana why didn't you just call
it UFC it's perfect
but clearly staging events is risky at
the moment just the day before last
weekend's UFC event a fighter had to
pull out after he and two of his corner
men tested positive underscoring the
fact that if you want to come back
completely without risk that's just not
possible right now and yet many sports
organizations are feeling real pressure
to ignore that risk especially college
sports where some schools athletic
programs rely heavily on revenue from
football and what you would hope the
coaches would talk about the trade-offs
of risk and safety with some tact
Oklahoma State football coach Mike Gundy
seemed completely comfortable saying the
quiet parts loud in my opinion if we
have to bring our players back test them
they're in good shape they're all 18 19
20 21 22 years old they're healthy a lot
of them can fight it off with it with
their natural body their antibodies and
bill that they have we need to continue
to budget and run money through the
state of Oklahoma Jesus Christ I don't
know who's medical advice is worth the
least in the middle of a pandemic but
guy who doesn't mind on page college
kids contracting a potentially deadly
disease so everyone else can make
millions is right down near the bottom
along with the advice of funeral parlor
magnate and the coronavirus wearing a
fake mustache
now don't II later apologized for those
comments but there was a real honesty to
what he said their profit is a powerful
motive
here especially for some team owners who
won't be the ones taking the risks and
it's why major sports like baseball and
football are so eagerly pursuing plans
to comeback but assuming that you can't
just stage all events in Jacksonville or
on some stupidly named island somewhere
how do you do it in the safest possible
way well for what it's worth
Anthony fell Chee has outlined how that
could happen there's a way of doing
there nobody comes to the stadium put
them in big hotels you know wherever you
want to play keep them very well
surveilled and mainly a surveillance but
have them tested like every week and
make sure they don't wind up infecting
each other or their family and just let
them play the season out yeah you just
isolate everyone involved and test the
hell out of them which intuitively seems
like it might work after all we already
have a show where a bunch of people with
incredible bodies get monitored all day
to make sure that they don't touch each
other
it's called too hot to handle and it is
perfect one of the hot idiots proposed
to one of the other hot idiots with a
Ring Pop and if you haven't watched this
show and you're still complaining about
being starved for content you're out of
your mind and ideas along the
lines of what felt you just proposed
so-called bubble leagues have been
floated for multiple sports at Major
League Baseball for instance was at one
point reportedly discussing plans to
play all of their games in Arizona and
on its face that seemed simple you just
seclude the teams and you have them play
with no fans but when you think about
that for more than a second it all
becomes much much more complicated
pickers of course you wouldn't just be
isolating players you'd be doing that
for coaching staff team physicians
trainers umpires clubhouse attendants
bus drivers camera crews and hotel staff
to name just a few by one estimate even
above a league would require nearly
10,000 people all of whom would need
constant testing and there is a key
distinction here because while pro
wrestlers are UFC fighters and college
athletes have no Union those in major
pro sports do and therefore they have
significant negotiating power so if you
want them to isolate themselves from
their families and put their lives at
risk
you need their agreement and some
big names like the Angels Mike Trout
still have some significant concerns
what are you doing family members my
wife is pregnant what am I gonna do and
you know she goes into labor am I gonna
have to quarantine for two weeks after I
come back cuz you know obviously I can't
miss that you know birth of her first
child yeah
he's right the league should not ask
anyone to miss the birth of their first
child that is a magic moment now second
child that's negotiable same
different day a third child I'm not even
sure the mother has to be there but that
first child is simply unmissable and
after pushback from multiple players
Major League Baseball has walked away
from the Arizona idea with an official
even saying earlier this month I would
be lying if we were to say we have a
good idea they're all degrees of bad and
that is true of so many current
proposals for sports to come back the
second you start reading the details of
any plan it automatically becomes
ridiculous
the MLB's new idea is to play an
abbreviated season in as many empty home
ballparks as possible but teams would
still have to travel to those meaning
they're not being quarantined and for a
sense of just how easy it is for
something to go wrong look at Germany
that country has handled this pandemic
much much better and they are in a very
very different situation than we are in
the US and that enabled their soccer
league to actually come back this
weekend employing a kind of bubble
league approach without fans and with
all team personnel quarantined in a
hotel but two players have already
tested positive forcing their entire
team to isolate for 14 days and one top
coach missed the first game after he
left the hotel to buy toothpaste and now
can't rejoin his team until he has two
negative tests and that shows just how
difficult it is to do any of this
effectively and look I will own the fact
I really want sports to come back there
is no doubt that they have the ability
to inspire one of the things that sport
does best is to bring people together in
times of crisis like when the Yankees
resumed playing after 9/11 unfortunately
no bringing people together is the exact
thing we should not be doing right now
and what sport was genuinely helpful at
the start of this crisis in showing us
how serious this virus was if it comes
back too soon and irresponsibly it won't
be an inspiration it'll be a cautionary
tale so as hard as it is to hear we
might need a little more time to make
sure that we get this right
phasing sports back in slowly with
tailored approaches that take into
account each sports level of contact and
robust systems of testing and tracing
and I know that there is currently an
absence in people's life so ideally what
you'd want is something that could fill
that gap for a while you know until
sports can return something with an
existing infrastructure schedule of
heart-pounding events a passionate fan
base and no human contact something to
which I'm obviously building if you've
been on Twitter lately you may have seen
this viral video marbles in the box and
they're often a neck-and-neck race up
there at the front all it actually comet
hits the divider the attenuator slows
him down and he falls back into third
place now under the clutches of deep
ocean so it's reflector out from the net
tarantula takes lead oh yes let me
introduce you to yellers marble bronze
they're based in the Netherlands and
they are a competitive marble racing
league that is to put it mildly
absolutely fantastic they upload races
to this YouTube channel on a regular
basis and nobody to whom we have shown
this including non-sports fans has not
ended up wanting to watch more there are
entire race tracks with marbles as fans
plus a marble tournament with 16
different events featuring relays water
courses and obstacles and there are also
backstories for the marbles involved and
some truly passionate fans 20,000 people
from around the world tuned in live to
watch last week's race and yellows
marble runs YouTube channel has millions
of views there are big fan bases built
up not just for the teams but for the
individual marbles and when one isn't
performing very well in the season
you're gonna hear about it on there and
and they will you know let that Marvel
know they got to pick up their game a
little bit now on the one hand that's
amazing on the other hand the marbles
don't really need fans to tell them when
they're off there
take a look at the midnight wisps they
came in fourth in their debut season
just missing the podium but did they
settle for that no they didn't they came
back the next year and they won it all
they use their shortcomings as
motivation to come back even stronger or
rounder I don't know
whichever adjective is best for marbles
the point is this isn't just a YouTube
distraction it's a beautiful competitive
event and the world needs those more
than ever right now
this is Marple league tournament is
actually due to start next month
unfortunately with times being hard the
league was struggling for money even
tweeting to make the mob League we need
sponsors a head sponsor and some smaller
sponsors so this beautiful thing is in
danger of going away just when we need
it the most
rather it was in danger because it turns
out they're not actually looking for a
sponsor anymore and the reason I know
that is you are looking at the new sole
sponsor of the upcoming Marvel League
tournaments that is right
we are proudly sponsoring all 16 events
over the next few months but weights
because there is a twist here in
addition to our sponsorship the winner
of each event will get $5,000 donated to
a food bank in their name
whether that name is the raspberry
racers the green ducks the Haze's or
even the Oceanics although frankly
they're going to need a ton of
reorganization in the locker room
because they were a mess last
year and what's more at the end of the
entire tournament
the overall winner will get a $20,000
donation made in their marble team's
name to the International Rescue
Committee it's it is the only way that
we could think of making what these guys
are doing even better so please check
this out and last week tonight Preserve
they come hazers to the lead green ducks
into the water now they have a lot of
trouble moving through those quick
chicane to start things off and the
savage speeders keep their momentum out
they fall into the final other
rasberry racers trying to fight for gold
the sports event of the summer
has arrived
we was knock dog fight
section raspberry racers they take the
lead neck-and-neck
[Applause]
marble League twenty20 premiering June
21st this one's for all the marbles
you